- ... everyone, and welcome
to my Why Python 3 video.
This video's also going to serve
as the first video in my Python 3
programming tutorial series.
Though, there will be nothing more
than just information on
Python 3 versus Python 2
in this video, and why you
should choose Python 3.
Video two will begin with the downloading
and installation of Python 3.
Also, I'm going to mention here,
and again later on in this series,
that this series is going to be geared
towards the complete noob for Python,
so if you're used to Python 2.7 already,
making the transition to Python 3
is really not that difficult.
I will probably make a Py2
to Py3 transitional video
after I finish this series,
but that's probably a little bit away.
So on with the video.
why Python 3?
So throughout my time with Python programming,
I've visited and revisited the idea
of Python 3 countless times.
When I first started, that's exactly what I did.
And I've always come up with
the exact same answer every time.
Python 3, on the whole,
is not better than Python 2.
Yet it has less support
documentation and libraries.
Basically, all of the good things in Python 3,
for the most part--
not all of them, but a lot of them--
have actually been ported
backwards into Python 2.
So more on why that might must
be really frustrating later.
But anyways, a few months ago
I watched a YouTube video
of a presentation about
why one should choose Python 3.
It was something like why Python 3?
Trust me, it's better.
(laughs) Something like that, right?
And it was given by an
actual developer for Python 3.
Through the entire presentation--
now, given it's probably just the case
that because I'm not an expert or a professional--
I guess professional is a bad word.
I am a professional, but I'm not an expert.
Through the entire presentation,
I was still left not really
seeing any reason,
based on that presentation
and what was said in that presentation,
I saw no reason to switch, right?
But instead, I could really sense the frustration
in this guy's voice, right?
The lack of adoption for Python 3
is actually an interesting topic of discussion.
The story of Python 3 could make
like a nerdy Greek tragedy movie
or something, seriously. (laughs)
Now, this stuff said, you know,
I'm not suggesting people
move to Python 3 out of pity.
That's not a very valid reason,
or a good idea at all.
But there are some good reasons
why you should move to Python 3.
See, Python 3 is really the future.
Python 2 is not.
If you stick with Python 2 and Python 2 only,
and everybody does this,
you're going to be able to
get away with it for a while,
and then you'll find yourself using Python 2
in a time where it's comparable
to using something like Pascal today.
At the same time, Python itself
will probably fall behind
as a developmental language
or a programming language,
just simply due to the lack
of support and community overall.
You know, Python, in my honest opinion,
is simply the best language out there.
It's very high level, yet it has incredible power.
And due to its high-level nature,
it's also very simplistic.
It's just a great language.
And it would be a shame
to really see it become outdated
just simply because the community
was disinterested in moving forward
with the language.
And, you know, I really can't imagine
how annoying it must be
for the Py3 developers,
that people just simply
aren't adopting the new language
for not too great of reasoning, in my opinion.
So in the end, the deciding factor for me
to not adopt Python 3 was the lack
of documentation and support, right?
It was, when I was a noob
to programming in Python,
and I really needed that support,
just as anybody new to any language
needs some sort of--
you need the community and the support
in order to progress in that language, right?
And I looked at both languages,
and to me they seemed equal.
Equal, but the community surrounding them
was very different in size,
so it seemed to make sense for me,
as a noob, to go with Python 2.7.
And I believe that's a logic--
I think that was a very logical choice.
And so anybody else that's doing the same thing,
I completely sympathize with
why that is the choice at the moment.
Now that I'm someone that has had this channel
and I'm making all these videos on YouTube,
I seem to be doing something right enough
to where at least a decent amount of people
enjoy how I teach, and I think it's almost somewhat
of my responsibility to share
and teach Python 3 at this point.
This way, maybe in the future when someone
does a search for Python 3 versus Python 2.7,
maybe they'll find my video,
or maybe they'll find stuff from people
that I helped get started,
or, you know, whatever,
and Python 3 can actually start to grow, you know?
Because for the most part right now
when you hear a Python 3
versus Python 2 discussion,
the differences are really only
geared towards, I would say the expert,
or at least professional Python developer,
but I would argue most professional Python developers
couldn't care less about these tiny differences.
And then the main question of performance:
Is Py3 or Py2 faster?
They are pretty much equal all the way down.
So there was, in the video from the guy,
trust me, Py3 is better,
or I forget the title,
but in that video he does
compare the performance,
and depending on the task,
sometimes Py2 is faster,
sometimes Py3 is faster.
The differences are so minute
that performance isn't the issue,
so it really comes down to a few
just tiny differences that, at the moment,
are so tiny that it just doesn't make sense.
But in the future,
if Python 3 is allowed
to continue growth and development,
Python 3 will be the victor.
But if, obviously, no one supports it,
then that sort of stuff
xis never going to happen,
and you won't have modules
and all this kind of stuff.
So...
Back to a video like like this guy, though,
by this time, that video's kind of geared
towards at least, most likely an expert.
And by that time that Py3 makes sense
to the expert, the developer
has already gone through their noob stage,
and probably did the whole
Python 2 versus Python 3,
decided Py2 was the best start,
and then got ingrained in their ways, right?
And then it's very hard
to get them to switch,
and a lot of people
don't see a reason to switch.
So here my goal is to offer a full slew
of beginner and partially
intermediate Python tutorials,
all using Python 3.
So my Python 2.7 tutorials will remain here.
I'm not going to delete them or anything,
but I'm going to be doing my best to offer
the same topics,
only in Python 3.
And some modules that are
pretty popular in Python 2
still aren't available in Python 3,
so we can work on at least probably covering
at least one of those modules
as far as how you could port them,
because really porting them
isn't that big of a deal.
Some of them are harder than others.
But anyway, this way, hopefully
you'll be able to get through
that noob and intermediate
stage of learning Python,
and you'll be able to do it with Python 3.
So with that, let's go ahead and start Python 3.
As always, everyone, thanks for watching.
Thanks for all the support and subscriptions.
Until the next video.